next step for jake is religion
he like cult is next you know like yeah
he'll be held up not like actual cult
you know like but he's gonna be held to
like a jesus level by the people of ohio
yeah
because he's basically you think that's
how it starts he yeah he likes he like
uh
basically is becomes mayor
of chicago i mean not chicago ohio
that's a state yeah doesn't have a mayor
but you get it what city is he from
um
i think uh miami miami ohio
is he no i don't know
what i do know is he's pro-labor rights
and um all the liberal arts majors are
having a really hard time with that
right now so so yeah explain explain
this to me what do you what exactly do
you mean do you mean because he
he did that like constantly yeah sorry
go ahead no it's fine he did that whole
thing with dana he's like i made a
challenge to you i'll retire from boxing
if you
you know i'll fight jorge monster don't
mma if you pay fighters more money and
he's
he in his video
to dana there's a response video because
it's like this whole back and forth let
me not jump ahead
he
so he calls out dana for paying the
fighters 12k a fight and he's like you
need to raise it to 50 and you need to
give them health care
and um
you know
uh
a lot of left people on twitter lost
their noodles because it was a it was a
moral conflict inside it's like it's
jake paul
but he's really pushing for labor rights
here god god damn it he's right yeah
i hate that he's right
can you imagine jake becoming like a
leftist like [ __ ] boy like his next
picture he's like naked but he's
covering his dick with like the
communist manifesto manifesto in his
mirror
and he's like
just learning how capitalism is so bad
for us
[Laughter]
i'm a marxist now dana don't call me
jake call me the marksman cause i'm
about the people
yeah so you know so the thing is though
he's actually is right
right he is he is about fighting
yeah like it's very traditionally
they are underpaid over
they're overworked sort of i mean they
go out there they risk their brains
every single time yep and the people on
the bottom don't get [ __ ] for it no
the the story of mighty mouse i think is
like the most horrible one
that's what is that
he
well you know he saw how stuart little
got so much fame and he was like i can
do that too
so
um
he
you know what i'm saying all right never
mind um no stuart little sorry the mouse
movie
maybe
i don't know what you don't know stuart
has a bad memory dude
okay that's fair
um anyway i don't remember the plot
you remember the mouse right remember
no
it looks like a mouse i'm guessing
stuart little is a mouse he's a rat was
he a boxer
uh well no mighty mouse is the boxer
ratatouille that's a good movie
[Laughter]
dude that rhymed i've seen that one no
anyway that dude mighty mouse he [ __ ]
um he works construction you know like a
[ __ ] 50 hour a week construction job
he would get off his 12s
and then um go train at an mma gym for
like two hours you know like he'd get
off of like what i imagine is like an
overnight shift
uh and he did that forever and
i you know i'm sorry is this a is this a
cartoon is this an actual this is real
this is real this is a real guy his name
is mighty mouse and he's here yeah yeah
demetrius johnson yeah okay got it and
i'm i'm just
uh
he is like when i say he's the worst
story i just feel like having to work a
construction job he's actually a good
story because he ended up becoming like
a ufc champion and all that and he
fights still professionally now
but some of my friends still train and
they tell me about guys that are
currently in the ufc and these dudes are
[ __ ] electricians and then they just
train in their spare time they go fight
for their [ __ ] twelve thousand
dollars and then they go back to their
electrician job like that next monday
so
you know
ufc's not not uh good in the way that
they treat their fighters because they
just keep all the money
because like technically by that point
you're a professional fighter like
you're a pro fighter
that's trying to that is putting in
full-time work
but not making enough to support
yourself so it's not
you guys gonna say if you fight on the
side and you have a job
and you're fighting professionally but
you're not like
doing it full-time then it's fine to
have a job
but you're saying these guys are putting
in full-time hours
into fighting and they're just like not
getting paid enough yeah dude imagine
working 40 hours a week for three months
and then at the end of that you get 12k
and then um before you even pay your
taxes on all that or after you pay taxes
and all that you got to divvy that [ __ ]
up to all the people you hired to like
enable you to win
if you even [ __ ] win yeah actually i
think you get 12k even if you lose but
still
that's [ __ ]
you know
yeah
so um
yeah uh jake paul so anyways
literally like
gonna replace aoc like literally the
next like
democratic representative
for america honestly um
i mean that guy's literally he's going
to be he's going to post a picture
on his instagram like you know full of
jewelry like just bust down
like you have you ever seen a picture of
him recently like the amount of [ __ ]
jewelry he wears yeah is nuts but he's
his shirt his t-shirt is going to say
eat the rich yeah and be like
and he's not going to get uh yelled at
for it everyone's going to applaud him
oh my god
jake is finally turning a corner
man i don't even like say this like to
be like really that hateful but that
picture he posted with drake he looks
deranged man
wait which one
which picture it was like on the dat pif
twitter it was like jake paul with drake
he looks [ __ ] deranged dude
he looks like a mad scientist
it might have been the same picture that
somebody sent i don't know it was a
collage
or a carousel sorry and one of them like
his new haircut
i got it right here i don't even i hate
that i just that i know about jake
paul's haircut kind of ironic honestly
but whatever haircut he's got he's got
like that face tattoo now that sort of
like goes in it's like an ear tattoo
it's like a
skull whatever right here yeah and like
bleeds into his face a little bit and
then he's not you now got this cream
can you like zoom in on that a little
bit
i just took cody out of whatever point
he was trying to make he just got
like
holy [ __ ] the eyes dude i'm saying like
he looks like he's trying to kill the
powerpuff girls he seriously
like
like he has a giant bomb in his basement
with the atomic symbol on it and it's
like
you know he's just down there like i
will take over the world
it's honestly a pretty dope look
yeah [ __ ] coke i'm a fan
he converted me
yeah he's converted a lot of people man
um that's good so yeah you're not
democratic candidate of uh
2024 jake paul everybody